Bottomless and mysterious.
The sky twinkling down on us with thousands of stars has enchanted people.
Since the beginning of times,
curiosity has always pushed mankind to explore new expenses and break
new grounds.
Eventually the first for knowledge and the technological progress enabled us to
art, exploring beyond our native planet. This step stirred sight,
its curiosity still more and very soon news face Wanderers left
the earth to travel to different corners of the solar system. And even further,
they were devoid of emotions and senses of either doubt or fear for these
Scouts of the us, where machines
Cause Mo the first and outer space,
roughly half a year before this video was posted on the
15th of April, 2021,
the automatic space probe in new horizons became the fifth spacecraft in the
history of the humanity to go beyond the point of 50 astronomical units from the
sun.
It was the voyages that had crossed this mug before with the probes pioneer 10
and pioneer 11, the first ever to do so.
None of these space Wanderers are likely to ever return to the earth with
some of them still active on their missions. Others have gone quiet forever
spacecraft,
new horizons start of mission 19th of January,
2006, distance to earth, 52 astronomical units,
spade 14 kilometers or three astronomical units per year.
Main goal Pluto and Sharon mission status successfully
completed condition operational,
just like most other interplanetary space probes.
New horizons performed a gravity assist,
maneuver near Jupiter before set out to its target.
Not only did it greatly boost the spacecraft speed,
but also allowed it to capture high quality images of the largest planet in the
solar system, alongside its satellites.
Besides the probes cameras captured the first video ever of an erupting volcano
on the surface of Jupiter, satellite IO,
after the gravity boost had been completed,
the probe made for the main target Pluto.
The spacecraft reached the planetoids and environs in January, 2015.
The mission's main goal was to explore Pluto and Sharon from different
perspectives that involved taking photos of and mapping these remote space
objects surfaces. In addition,
the probe estimated the magnetic fields values and the solar wind activity close
to the objects and collected information about their atmospheres and surface
reflection properties.
It goes without saying that the program also involved search for Pluto's as yet
on detected satellites and more accurate measurements of Pluto's orbits
parameters. Having completed the main mission, the probe continued to be useful.
It flew beyond Pluto's orbit and went on to explore objects in the pipe about
that is how our images of Koua R one and aoth were produced.
Thanks to the probes cameras, the distances to the stars,
Proxima centi and Wolf 3 59 were measured. Unfortunately,
the radio isotope generator onboard the spacecraft is expected to start running
low from 2026. And eventually all meters will switch off one.
After another new horizons will continue on its way beyond the boundaries
of the solar system. And by the year 2038,
the distance between the probe and the sun will have grown to be a hundred
astronomical units. By that time,
the energy generator onboard the spacecraft will have stopped operating
completely, and it will be impossible to get any connection with it.
Following a hyperbolic orbit, new horizons will exit our system,
never to come back.
The same thing happened with two other probes, pioneer 10 and pioneer 11.
They hit an escape trajectory from the solar system a while ago. In fact,
they were the first automatic space probes ever to be sent into inter Stella
space by humans,
spacecraft pioneer 10 start of mission. 3rd of March,
1972 distance to earth,
127 astronomical units speed,
approximately 12 kilometers per second or two and a half astronomical units per
year.
Main goal Jupiter mission status successfully
completed condition, not operational.
The spacecraft reached Jupiter system on the fourth of number 1973
after completing a 641 day journey through space
during the mission images of the gas giant surface and its largest satellites
were beamed back to the earth and the planet's atmospheric composition and
magnetic field were gauged. In addition,
Jupiter was found to AIT two and a half times more,
more energy than it receives from the sun.
The data unique at the time became the basis for understanding the makeup of gas
giants and their satellites.
The trajectory of the second probe pioneer 11 through space past Jupiter
two, but its main target was the other gas giant of our system.
Sudden the probes scientific instruments gauged the planet's magnetic field
and the cameras on board to quite a few snapshots,
not only of the gas giant itself and its system of rings,
but also two of its satellites, Titan and Mimus.
According to the estimates,
the current distance between pioneer 11 and the center of our system is around
106 astronomical units on completing their main mission.
Both probes continued on their way moving further and further away from the sun.
Unfortunately,
both of them are out of with the last signal from pioneer 10 received
back in 2003,
the last signal from pioneer 11 was received in 1995.
Supposedly both of them are now rapidly moving beyond the boundaries of the
solar system. Incidentally,
having no chance of ever catching up with either of the two probes while going
to talk out next, the pioneers were launched at a much earlier date
spacecraft Voyager, one start of mission,
5th of September, 1977, distance to earth,
154 astronomical units speed around
17 kilometers per second,
or 3.6 astronomical units per year main goal
Jupiter and Saturn mission status successfully completed
condition, not fully operational.
The contribution of Voyager one to the so systems X exploration can hardly be
overestimated.
It is thanks to this probe that several new Jupiter satellites were discovered
alongside its ring system, which was big news.
The voyages cameras captured volcano eruptions on IO and provided hard
evidence that Jupiter's great. Red spot is an enormous storm.
The probe beamed back hundreds of photos of the largest planet of our Sola
system and its satellites. After the spacecraft crossed,
Neptune's orbit the meters on board,
SunEd back a great amount of valuable data about inter Stella plasma Voyager.
One left both the carpet belt and the Helia Poe behind a long while ago is now
rapidly crossing the area of the solar system,
scattered disc making for the inner boundary of the hypothetical or cloud.
It is not only the remotest manmade object in space,
but also the fastest of all the spacecraft on our way to exit our system.
Being the first space probe to have traveled that far from the center,
the solar system Voya one offered scientists,
a unique opportunity to study the heli pause.
This is the area around our sun where solar wind pressure and Intella gas
pressure balance.
When the charged particles emitted by the star collide with rarefied plasma,
elaborate structures form out of elementary particles and, and magnetic fields,
studying them is crucial for understanding processes,
taking place in the universe.
Unfortunately by around the year 2025,
the power of the radio isotope thermoelectric generators onboard the probe will
have run out completely and the connection will have been lost in 300 years.
Voyager one is estimated to reach the inner boundary of the hypothetical or
cloud.
It will take the spacecraft approximately 30,000 years to go clean through.
And after that, it will fly beyond the boundaries of the so system,
10,000 years later, still the probe will fly by the star.
Gleer 4, 4, 5 at a distance of 1.6 flight years,
and then it will eventually get lost in the infinite depths of outer space.
Speaking about Voyager one, we can't,
but mention its twin launched from the earth on the 20 19th of August, 1977,
Voyager two had Saturn Uranus and Neptune for its targets,
but it also approached Jupiter for a gravity boost.
It's the images taken by this probe that allowed scientists to assume that there
are subsurface oceans on ADE and Europa on reaching SU
Voyager two gauge the gas giants,
temperature and magnetic field and discovered several new satellites.
It goes without saying that lots of snapshots were taken of both Saturn surface
and its rings next in line on the probes way where Uranus and Neptune,
the flyby yielded a great number of unique snapshots.
And in total 17 know the two planet satellites were discovered.
Also it was found that both UUs and Neptune have ring systems under
Neptune's gravitational influence,
the spacecraft changed its trajectory and left the ecliptic plane.
This meant that Voyager two wouldn't be able to approach the other objects and
solar system, but it still had other exciting things to look forward to.
Thus the probe was to collect in valuable data about Interstella plasma and
cosmic wind, as well as to measure distances to stars and explore the hee.
The probe is currently as far as 128 astronomical units away from the center
of our system with a distance growing by fit 15.37 kilometers.
Every second,
it's going to take it around 42,000 years to approach Ross 2 48
at dim red dwarf in the constellation Andro,
the minimal distance between Voyager two and the star will be about 1.7 light
years. And around 3000 years since its launch, chances are,
it will fly by serious at a distance of 4.3 light years.
Unfortunately it is impossible to distinguish such a tiny object from the earth
that far away
we'll live at the Dawn of space exploration and into planetary space.
Probes are just he's first timid steps in exploring the infinite universe.
It is hard to predict their fate.
They may be smashed on collision with a celestial body,
or they may be recapture by our distant descendants who will have advanced into
stellar travel technologies.
To the point of being able to catch up with the probes for all we know they
might recover them from space and put on display in a museum,
but it is more likely that the fragile apparatus are destined to drift on for
years and years through the lifeless expanses and millions years later,
radioactive Ray and rare particles of cosmic dust whizzing through the probes
time and time again will eventually wear them down to thread, bird,
debris to be scattered across the depths of the universe without a trace.